an upper gastrointestinal endoscopy
also called hezo [ __ ]
straw duodenal skopies or gd is a
procedure that allows your doctor
to look at the inside lining of the
upper part of your gastrointestinal tract
this includes your heating your
stomach and your duodenum
l  Upper gastrointestinal endoscopy
is used to assess symptoms
of persistent upper abdominal pain
nausea vomiting
bleeding or difficulty swallowing
it can accurately detect
inflammation infection tumor ulcer
or any other disorder present the
procedure involves using an
endoscope which is  a tube the onf a
hose equipped with a small,
light video camera attached to its end the
camera transmits an image to a screen
before the endoscopy an
intravenous line is created and you receive
painkillers and a sedative
your blood pressure your  your pulse and
the level of oxygen in your blood are
checked during the procedure
your doctor may spray your throat
ask you to gargle with a
local anesthetic which will numb your
throat you will need to lie on your
left side
a supportive dental retractor will be
placed in your mouth
in some cases you will receive
supplemental oxygen through a
nasal cannula uncomplicated upper endoscopies
usually take
10-20 minutes your doctor will
gently squeeze the endoscope through your
mouth and gently and carefully move it
through your  heating
to reach your stomach and finally
your duodenum
you should feel no pain
during this step your doctor may
periodically introduce a small
amount of air to flatten the mucosa
and optimize visibility
if your doctor wishes to collect a
tissue sample
he may perform a  or more
biopsies through the endoscope for later examination
the biopsy can distinguish
benign tissue from cancerous tissue
also use it to detect
helicobacter pylori the bacteria that
can cause ulcers your doctor
can also use the endoscope to
treat  a disorder someone ulcer
causing bleeding therefore or
might draw a stricture to the
wild water or stomach crunch
after the procedure you will be monitored
until the effects of the medication
have worn off your throat may be irritated
you may feel slight
bloating you will then have to
plan your return home